he's hall of famer michael wilbon espn's
pardon the interruption co-host nba
analyst as well and a graduate of
northwestern is northwestern a party
school michael
no okay not in not in the way
that we think of party school you're
going back to for those of us a certain
age you would follow the
playboy magazine party school list
decade after decade no i mean we know
how to
find a good time or have a good time
but party school and the way that
i could think of other party schools no
if i gave you i loved it i wouldn't put
it in for a time at any party school but
party i wouldn't call it
okay if i gave you a do-over and you
could go to a party school
but you have to pick a school well i'm
right now as i sit about 25
minutes from tempe arizona at arizona
state university
that is a card carrying member of
party school brigade i think
i think i'd be uh a sun devil fan
they're up there on the mount rushmore
it feels like of a party school
all right i was watching uh you and tony
yesterday and the topic of major league
baseball came up
and i could just and tony said it's
groundhog's day here
like you have to talk about it but
there's nothing to talk about here
and i and i keep saying to my audience i
hate doing this to you
but i feel obligated to at least touch
on it every single day
i just can't advance it that's right
and dan as you know this isn't the first
time
um i mean baseball threatens to blow
itself up every
few years when there's a labor
negotiation and they've done it
once they've done it more than once but
1994 of course is the year they actually
did
and just just just blew up not just a
season but a tremendous season of season
that was
shaping up i guess as late as august to
be one of the great seasons one of the
great summers in baseball history that
they've done it and so they'll do it and
i guess
i don't know 30 percent of me thinks
they they won't do it this time they
can't do it this time
it would be nothing is unforgivable in
the world because or a few
things are because of the shelf life and
people forgive and they even if they
don't forget they come back to you
but dan and i keep thinking okay they'll
get it done because they realize the
consequences
of not getting it done this summer
but 70 of me is now thinking you know
what
these sides are hateful enough of each
other
in this context of labor negotiation
that they they will do it they'll do it
again
and so i'm i what i don't know i don't
know what you do
what do you think what give me give me
your odds now of baseball
actually having a season versus not i
talked to a smart guy yesterday
and a tv executive and he said
don't get caught up you know you got to
see it
it's like the trees in the forest here
and he said don't get caught up in that
that there's too much money they'll
eventually get something it might not
resemble what you think a baseball
season is but they will put a product
out there they understand the stakes
the owners know you know what what the
gray area is
the players association knows the gray
area you have to clean that up a little
bit in the margins
and they'll eventually play baseball and
they go all right
he goes don't quote me but they're gonna
they're gonna play they're gonna play
baseball um a couple things here
i know that espn shies away from talking
politics we get caught up in this stick
to sports couple years ago with the
colin kaepernick the anthem
and you probably got a memo or there was
an edict of let's
talk sports here now we come back around
to this with george floyd
with what happened and then the fallout
here with all of the players involved in
this like
how do you not incorporate this in the
rundown on pardon the interruption every
day or do you get any pushback on that
no we haven't had any pushback and you
know me willing enough to know i don't
read those
memos anyway i mean you're right i'm
sure they go out i
pay zero attention um and you
you know that this is what people are
talking about in the world
from your household to anywhere people
gather even if they don't want to even
if it's a whisper
even if there are pockets of people who
don't want to deal with it to not deal
with
what is clearly um
an emotional topic which affects sports
it affects sports is going to affect
us wait till we get to the nfl season
and like a
third of the people players are kneeling
or you know you may get coaches or you
may get i mean the way the roger goodell
has sounded lately
it wouldn't shock anybody if he took a
knee to start a game we get to september
um and so this is this is it's it's
the story one of the stories of our
lives we're gonna look back
at 2020 and even in a pandemic
and maybe even partly because of the
pandemic
we're going to have you can't write the
history of this year you may not be able
to write
the history of a chunk of years here
without dealing with
this entire topic which of course is
precipitated
by the murder of george floyd what if we
just didn't have the anthem
and you allowed the players to go to the
middle of the field take a knee
to to start the game i mean i'm just i'm
just we didn't used to show this but i'm
just thinking out loud of
how do we do something that allows the
players to have their moment
and then we don't upset people who
who look at this differently than what
we may look at this
that you know what when i first heard
that suggestion i was like
no no you can't start these games
without the anthem
and i thought you could but okay how
about this and i wish i knew where i
read this
uh over the weekend what about a minute
after the anthem that allows people to
do whatever they want you can hold up a
sign
do whatever you want in the minute after
and i
i i thought oh god i wish i could i
should be able to attribute that but
i just thought you know what which is
sort of a
a a take a slightly different one off
what
that other suggestion is about not
having it
um and you know how you move off
positions
like one of the one of the favorite
things in my life dad in my life
is going to a blackhawks game chicago
blackhawks game
and hearing the playing of the anthem
yeah
and a gentleman named jim cornelison
singing the anthem and
the the standing ovation the passionate
deep pat you know guttural
uh applause and stomping for the for the
for the star-spangled banner
before every home blackhawks game it's
one of the great joys
i have like if i go to a blackhawks game
and piece somebody's meeting me i said
you you make sure you get there 20
minutes there's none of this los
angeles oh there's traffic i'm just
getting to my seat
after the puck drops you're not doing
that and so i
you know but you get conditions that
sometimes
move you off positions i might move you
off your original spot
and so it's not my favorite suggestion
dan
but you know what we're all having to
consider
new things new positions uh new ways of
doing things that will accommodate
the group and wow i don't want to go
there
but i'm not going to sit here and say oh
i think that's insane and should not be
considered because
i think we've got to consider a lot of
things now he's michael wilbon espn's
pardon the interruption
what role does colin kaepernick play in
colin kaepernick
maybe coming back to play it feels like
everybody's talking for colin kaepernick
where's colin kaepernick you know
it's been suggested not in 2016 17 or 18
but it's certainly been suggested the
last two years
the colin kaepernick isn't interested in
playing that he's good now with this
um and i don't want to be too cynical
because i don't i haven't believed
that i thought what the nfl did last
year with that sort of con by a fake
combine situation was just fraudulent on
every level
but i don't know kaepernick well enough
dan to i can't sit here and say oh wait
i talked to people who know him and he
absolutely wants to play i don't
know kaepernick that well um does he
want to play
and so it seems to me now
he might have a real opportunity not not
that fake fraudulent opportunity from a
year ago
um but dan have we how many owners have
we heard from it's
unbelievable we've heard from everyone
in the last eight to ten days everybody
we've heard from people you know we all
play the game dead or alive you know
someone said the name of a celebrity
we've heard from that person whether
it's on instagram or a statement
or you know you know a tmz microphone
we've heard from
everyone what nfl owner have we heard
from
we certainly haven't heard from jerry
jones like so
how resentful are the nfl owners gonna
be of
all of this including the guy who serves
them you know roger goodell how upset
they're gonna be at goodell
are we gonna talk about four to eight
nfl owners who are okay with this
are we gonna talk about 15 18 20
jerry jerry jones going to stand in this
position and you can't work for me
and take a knee i i think all of this i
mean we haven't even
seen the real controversy of the nfl yet
presuming there's a season we're gonna
see it
but i think the kaepernick question
boils down to
you know everybody says well tony tony
says this is this is the time we're
going to see change
and he likens it to when he was you know
a young man in his 20s and we were
coming through the late 60s and early
70s
and what we saw in the country i'm i'm
not that optimistic
and part of the reason is i don't know
what we're going to see from nfl owners
and toward their attitudes
about whether or not there's going to be
change in that culture
but also with kaepernick it feels like
this is the quarterbacking
the black quarterback version of the
rooney rule like hey
we're gonna bring in and it feels like
tokenism it just doesn't feel real that
like what has changed other than
kaepernick has gotten older
now he gets a chance because why because
you feel
bad because you blackballed him and if
i'm kaepernick i go
nope i'm not letting you off that easy
here
well yes i yes i completely agree with
everything you said
you know what again part of it goes back
to
again i don't want to be too cynical
about this because i think this is
obviously this is such a sensitive issue
does kaepernick like being perceived as
a martyr
like what's what what's his agenda how
much money did he get
from the nfl and what what what were the
terms of that
like i i truly believe you know the
piece howard bryant uh having espn.com
this weekend which i thought was a
brilliant piece
talked about goodell not mentioning its
name i don't know what that agreement
included
like it's part of me given that given
that the commissioner just completely
gave it up right for that group of
players who was in that video last week
late last week
the not mentioning of kaepernick's name
seems to have an agenda
yeah like what else is in there what if
he what if he and the kaepernick or the
league and kaepernick agreed to that we
don't know
because remember do we know the
financial terms we don't even know that
right
like we don't know how much money he got
i was told that it was nowhere near what
was reported it was probably around
five million dollars that people were
estimating it was 50 million i was told
it was 5 million for kaepernick yeah i
was maybe i was toward your end of it
i'm thinking like 10
but not but the notion that it was 20 or
more i it just seemed to me to be
un-nfl-liked
unless they prove i mean unless they
perceive something else was coming
that they wanted to sidestep like and
including discovery
but man the kaepernick issue is
you know dan in some ways look this guy
i don't want to turn him into john
carlos and tommy smith because i don't
believe he he was that the the suffering
is on a different scale the sacrifices
on different skill but he had the guts
he had the guts to do this and then he
sort of lost
me personally when he said i didn't vote
people died for the right to vote and he
said i didn't vote
and this is the the most fundamental
exercise we have in a democracy even
more
so or as much um as the right to
to to free speech and protest and an
assembly and
so but i i go back to he had the guts to
do this
he was a fine player if anybody wants to
look around the nfl and tell me
kaepernick's not better
than like 28 of the backups and probably
15 of the starters i mean i
live in a city i root 14 that hasn't had
a quarterback as good as kaepernick
since you know jim mcmahon so
like i don't want to hear that colin
kaepernick can't play in the nfl because
that's just an insult and a lie
does he want to does he want to and is
some are several somebodies
going to create what we call a market to
see if that happens
i got my doubts mike good to talk to you
my best at tony
and uh hopefully we'll uh get a chance
to cross paths here soon
dan would love that man thanks for
having me appreciate it it's michael
wilbon hall of famer